we're going to talk about rhetoric
identities now I wonder if you remember
when we were back in algebra we talked
about three connected objects that gets
the touch on what we're looking at right
now we talked about expressions we
talked about if you've got one
expression and it's equal to another you
call that and equation which of course
has photos its cousins inequalities
which are related but not quite and then
we beam algebra we have these guys the
identities which is what we're focusing
on today in it's different topic and you
remember what was it that made and
identity different from an equation
what's the difference
second largest identities are true all
the time no matter what values you
supply for the perennial example here's
an equation it's only true for one value
of x at that point break what but if you
put in any other X you've stopped right
identities on the other hand on true
regardless of whatever values you
started to implement if a was one and
there was a million it still be true if
a with science B was negative 3 in still
be true identities our favorite of
equality that slides I don't care what
have you put into me okay and in
trigonometry it's exactly the same now
you know it require a few identities
already we just haven't really labeled
them as such ok question
just wait your turn left okay so firstly
directly giving what you already know we
had some reciprocal identity right so we
have that Cosette and cost each of them
is a reciprocal of another one
assumption that you're a little more
familiar with which on which set that's
one over cost go back and that leaves
one over hand for kott so we've seen
these before and the whole point is we
define them in this way these are always
true they are always equal to each other
no matter that what are you finding is
fine the research you will know about
these as well out of the six
trigonometric functions that you have
two of them are ratios of other trig
functions which one but it can and
caught very good so can we know what a
right angle train was opposite on
adjacent but you can also state it as
410 regular tan that's fun a closet
weight is yes the reciprocal of course
which we just wrote up above therefore
is also a ratio between two other true
ratios racial reference so copy die from
life and climbing up on sine theta and
by the way from masters next to this one
that's important because some values we
actually encountered this the other day
when we were drafting some days of tan
don't exist
strange you remember that within our
normal not to 360 domain which values of
theta don't exist 90 90 and 270 you get
a vertical asymptote on this guy right
however if all you've got is this is
your definition
if you put in 90 degrees then this I
will spit out to you 1 / undefined both
glasses right it's the same thing with
theta equals 270 if you put into TR
you'll get 1 divided by undefined
however you come to dick dying you
notice for example clots follow 90
degrees what is that what is caused a 90
degree on sine of 90 degrees now we're
at 10 blew up as soon as you try not to
do it doesn't blow up at all
what's cause nice if 0 + 5 90 is 1 so
that's fine and we grasp that we saw it
it works so you need these a sort of arm
for each other compliments you also know
some of the functions are complementary
not as little okay nice haircut as in as
the 90 degrees okay which is the most
important one in yoga yes sine theta and
cos theta now here is the way that I
would write a bit of variety of
different ways to write the things like
minute clearance cause of 90 - fear
cause of 90 minus theta
that's Isis one of the ways you can see
this and it'll be helpful if you told
it's over here on the right hand side
just for me a right angle triangle any
right angle triangle Chuck a cedar in
there so these in sine theta in this
particular triangle did have what should
t be summation shall we let's call this
a and this is B right so sine theta in
this triangle is everything geography
opposite on high polish where is 90
minus theta
even channel where is it
yeah it's the angle eyes I haven't
labeled that there's 19 - er do you see
why cause of that pi is the same ratio
because it's additional hypotenuse such
as component now columns we abbreviate
it cause because times electro sign
every single time but that helps you
recognize with Co stands for compliments
there are two other key functions that
also start with current one adding
perfect and caught right now also I
really mentioned it but they're also
complementary identities so she is the
way we write for a hot one
if the complement of can so this is your
pen and then the last one is Cosette
that's the complement of it should look
at it it's the complement of sec bigger
it's the reciprocal of side but it's a
complement of set design a fence that's
like it means complement or set the
football okay good news these very often
but you still need to recognize them and
with your every doubt about them you
just fine